with so the crystal gems are evil looks
like I owe you a cook Smithers well that
we know of may just the whole depent you
know defending the earth is just cover
they really want to blow it up now
they're probably okay um I was cowering
though they are kind of fugitives or
whatever at least out castle it sounds
like they were like the original
defenders or whatever earth or maybe
they're like I know I mean we convicted
of a crime they didn't really commit
deit no I was gonna say just love um but
uh yeah I mean this is another one where
we get some more information peridot
comes back I love that name um and a lot
of cool
I'd only way I can describe it is stuff
I loved it in like miyazaki movies and
like in Waterworld and stuff whereas our
show is how the made-up technology works
and let you know what I will say this
this always happens I think in like
cartoons and stuff and and movies and I
feel like it's all this alien technology
that is working way too hard to do the
simplest things like to activate the end
to like take this thing down do this and
then becomes like this drop and then
turns into a marble thing it's a button
I'm like really there was no easier way
somehow to do well but I mean it's
because we don't understand it maybe
someone like from a different world or
past whatever you know comes and sees
like what we go through to drive a car
and tornad and all the rules worth of
Jones get me wrong it looks cool it was
great and I usually was awesome but I
always kinda sit back I'm like wow for
such an advanced civilization they have
these needlessly complicated ways of
doing things like flipping a switch but
we also don't okay we don't know how
complicated like a lot of stuff is I
mean it's kind of like going to a
nuclear missiles like we can't just push
a button and watch it well sure but you
kind of want a little bit more caution
with it no we need more safety features
we need marbles
yes um well that's kind of what I liked
about this episode too cuz okay so the
gems I mean we talked about before are
definitely you know shoot first ask
questions never and Steve is trying to
fix that beeping me was like that I love
that line where he's just like why think
now's the most appropriate time to ask
questions when they're just like we have
an enemy that we know nothing about
now's not the time to ask questions well
I think that's the perfect time to ask
questions I'm like well he's cut but I
he's always diplomatic which it's
definitely showing the benefits of Ed
ties but you know I was just thinking
this episode too you know funny the
funny thing is is like they're like we
learned that this was a bad idea but
really for the sake of the audience I'm
like Stephen did the right thing because
I'm like well now we know
well no but on top of that they did say
we know more than we did before if he
didn't go up there but we might have
just brought a whole ton of hell on us
you know and most likely if I probably
Gary even advanced the plot so it was
good that he did what he did well yes
for us but for them it's kind of half
and half um but no but that's what I'm
saying I was saying you they're not
telling him anything so fuck that no
souma did I fuckin told them then we the
audience would need this scene either
that's captured too um but there's so
many times were like diplomas there's a
time for diplomacy and there's a time to
be goober uber cautious and paranoid um
and I like the fact that show is never
one or the other it's like there's and I
think it makes very clear you're not
going to know when and you're gonna make
mistakes with it sometimes it's right to
go in and just guns a-blazing other
times it's right to you know talk it
through but you're never fully gonna
know you just have to use your best
judgment and your best judgment is not
always going to be right if I think it's
statistically impossible frame was best
judgment always be right yeah my
favorite line is from garnet just like
you know we can't stop these things
forever well yes we can but I don't want
to Roger I want to yeah that was
brilliant I'll I also I also liked the
the control room lady or whatever at the
end just I'm gonna report it sound like
it was very much just I'm telling well
you know what I like about that too I
laughed at that line but then what I
thought about him like that could be
really bad like there's others there's
people above her like who's all gonna
know about this and what are they
do i I thought they really got the
tension in this episode really well for
just you don't know what's going on and
you legitimately are not sure is this
okay or is this not is this peridot
person you know actually a good person
just looks bad or looks bad and is bad
you know and I think there's just all
this uncomfortable tension throughout
the whole thing and when you're seeing
Steven talk to her you're also kinda
like okay where where is this go and
like you you don't want to see him get
hurt you don't want see anything bad
happy you just had no idea what angle
it's gonna take um I mean for the most
part the gems seem to be right that
pretty much everything that comes there
is trying to kill them and do bad stuff
um you know it doesn't want to listen to
them but you also kind of take Steve
inside where it's like okay not
everything can be evil now I mean they
definitely tried to attach them emotion
when she crushed that one marble a few
episodes ago you know just like or kind
of cute' whatever they're just splat you
know and now why would you give this
episode this there were marbles and
there was Samantha's yes um as
advertised
yeah um no I feel like there's plot yeah
like it gets excites me like it's like
the the piecemeal way of doing it was
good but I feel like finally like okay
we're seeing more of these episodes now
where they're actually know let's
advance the story um you know and even
the side episodes because the previous
one felt more like a side episode but
that was still advancing this all right
this is filling in the blanks about you
know Rose amethyst Stephens dad and so
ya know I the good a pretty good pace
yeah yeah certain easy sighting ships
exciting um there's sort of this thing
with like yeah like gravity falls
Adventure Time of this show it probably
even more where they like a good half of
them are kind of as I as we call filler
episode you know hey just something
goofy maybe you learn a little something
about character gray maybe the tiniest
bit about the flies dropped in but then
you have the other half which is like
continuing this big mystery
um and it's one of those things where it
I'm always interested in the mysteries
of in all of these shows I've never not
been interested in what was going on
the funny thing is gravity falls not so
much actually like the writing I thought
was so solid and funny that I the
mysteries fine I'm not saying I hate it
I totally enjoy it but it's not
something that I'm like oh I'm in this
for the mystery this one's the opposite
I think the writings decent and the
jokes are decent but like the mystery I
find more interesting then well and with
when there's a side episode I'm a little
more like in gravity falls when there's
a side episode generally I'm like he's
writing so good yeah it's still really
funny this one I'm just like what that
was fun there was a little Zen kind of
meditation there just some random stuff
that happened but I'm like what's going
on with it
oh so um I will say with the only one I
can think of that never fully addresses
I mean maybe one or two little ones but
like Adventure Time never fully says hey
there's a big mystery here and we're
trying to figure it out it's more like
once in a while there's something that's
like oh I want to know what's going on
with like whatever like as a father in
it and stuff like that but that's Cavis
I think they more kind of like in a way
with this one does they sort of drop the
information that they already know
except Stephen doesn't know it so we
want to know cuz he wants to know
obviously um what'd you think of the was
it the unfamiliar familiar oh my god I
like that second okay in like 30 seconds
this show literally satirized and summed
up 20 years of kids books like young
adult books IV yeah young adults I tend
to just group them together but why is
it in 30 seconds the cover would like
the owl and the girl or whatever glowing
and then now the title the unfamiliar
familiar the fact that it's part of a
series every description they gave when
Stephen was describing but I'm like wow
this is every single thing that I have
seen in the past 20 years in young adult
fiction not saying that's a bad thing
and then young adult fiction overall
it's pretty good the fact that everyone
is talking and reading now is really
amazing event that's not like oh I'm
pissing on young adult fiction no I'm
just saying this it's so nailed the the
kind of like style and tropes that we've
been in in the past like 15 to 20 years
the I'd say even pre Harry Potter like
you know cuz there's gold in your cup is
mainly I got out of it yeah I was
thinking Golden Compass Harry Potter
Percy Jackson Artemis Fowl um the with
them blanking on it launched oh yeah
there was there's a series of even older
books that were about like oh but that
overseen under stone was the first one
in the series anyway it was really good
they made a really shitty movie out of
it not too long ago the YouTube will
explain it the commenters will be like
that movie watcher that's what my beauty
comments do like half the work for us we
tell remember something it's like what
kind of comment you'll see it yeah it
was a series of four or five books they
were all really good the first was
oversee under stone and then they called
the movie The Seeker The Watcher
somebody was fucking terrible i sat
through like twenty minutes it was
nothing like the book so I'm totally
blanking on it right now but all of
those books it was a good spoof of like
all of those books
well I was wondering if like when he
reads him out of order and she's like no
you know you know who plink it is as
Lisa's father and you're not supposed to
know that yeah you know you're reading
about a little Emma Luke the the cup
okay this is purely at you thing because
like you know the comments are gonna
explain in there I know but it's drained
the probably vibe already who hasn't
finished the video and it's just like
I've already said what it is I don't
know it's driving me nuts right now I
want to know now but here's my theory
I'm wondering if the when she's like so
shocked that he's read ahead he's
reading them out of order uh if that's a
comment on people watching this show out
of order uh
getting sufficient mean Google yay dark
is rising see that's the problem I kept
laying that stays dark materials I'm
like no I'm like it was dark something
the darkest Rising series are sequin
they're really awesome you should read
them and I also felt like it was kind of
like kind of spoof in there than like
yeah now that those are older though
that's like 1965 but like they keep
getting really yeah I gotta have you
like yeah I kind of feel like they they
go back but they've they've had a huge
boom recently well the pan I feel like a
lot of recent fiction young adult
fiction owes something to kind of that
obviously Tolkien was a diversity CS
Lewis all of that so um but yeah like so
brilliant spoof of everything that's
been going on in the past 20 years in 30
seconds yeah like I'm like I was one of
the best written bits I've ever seen in
like a kid show so well and they had the
the episode prior I think they had some
of those books or maybe not but the
father said um really books are popular
again and it is one of those things
where it's like I mean people growing up
now it's like because young adult blogs
and kids wings I mean they just put so
much more effort help really anything
kind of kid related has much more effort
now yeah oh yeah I feel like in the 80s
it was more video games yeah and we
definitely on that too
but comics but yeah I mean I feel like
the high schoolers were still reading
through the 80s and there was a lot of
good stuff going on but it was like four
huge these books like the 80s I'm trying
to think um I remember a lot of reading
no I mean Harry Potter is really the
thing that kind of read cause you had to
yeah Harry Potter was like the huge
explosion like you know we're gonna make
reading actually popular I mean you know
I mean before it was like if you read
it's like well okay but who does that
you know you're a bookworm you're a nerd
and stuff like that but it's like not
everybody fucking reads Harry Potter and
all that stuff so it is one of those
things where it's like it's fucking
wonderful I mean I'm so happy it up I
think you're right in how they sir
summed up that young adult almost genre
uh you know you know the younger than
nothing man now see the young adult yeah
to seizure and then somehow you know
it's sort of a different genre maybe not
but throwing the apocalypse or like not
the apocalypse a world taken over by
evil I really the 1984 I love the the
titles to recovery destinies and I'm
like man they've yeah
no they really really got it oh you know
like a peaceful way without loving homes
that's what I like to add to is not
insulting that style of book it just was
like here it is like you're like kind of
our spoof of all of these things I'm
like why it really freaking me they show
something I'm noticing this show has
while it's funny and intense and and
interesting stuff it has this
fascinating power of not being
mean-spirited
nothing's yet mean-spirited about it um
you know everybody looks different and
odd and it's strange but they're very
rarely whole thing about it it's where
we fucking hate wars cuz he's like the
only outlier so I wanna hate everything
and stuff yeah like yeah he's he's still
mostly harmless he's just annoying yeah
you're right he's only what it seems
kind of mean spirited like everyone else
like you know just has like they'll say
yeah and it's ours everybody large its
large and Lars is cynical and
mean-spirited well Ronaldo's just a
fucking psycho yeah um so yeah but let's
we don't up into there Oh but anywho uh
no I thought this was a good expert good
exposition while also trying to figure
out what's going on and again sort of
teaching kind of an interesting lesson
about like when it's right to be
diplomatic when it's you know right to
take action and but there's no solid
answers I really like that and I like
again with I sort of felt like we can't
start this with BAM a the animated
series but I like these kid shows at see
where I am big you do yeah there are no
solid answers you just guys what make a
man so grave like really half the time
it's like did Batman create this villain
or would they have been this twisted if
he wasn't there
yeah case you got a look at and have to
wonder my favorite it's just one episode
where Pam it just leads over to Robin
says sometimes there are no happy
endings that I'm just like I love the
show um oh yeah man thanks I don't
better know so um yeah a good episode
curious where it's going and yeah um I
think we should now that the formula is
down and concrete somebody should
clearly write the unfamiliar
miliar and have somehow I have destinies
and be the first book just to throw
people off Stephen are you reading them
in order
uh what's a familiar ah so that's it
um bye no funny ending in there